بعيدة عن ايدينا. يبدو ان التنين
الصيني قد ضغط على زر الساعة
وبدأ العد التنازلي لسيطرة الضبع
الامريكي على العالم. والسؤال
سنبتلع بكم العالم كله ولن تكون
هناك اي بقعة في هذا الكوكب
متطور ساعدها في تمردها المسلح
ضد بوتين لا تسمح حكومة بكين
سابقا. انتم قبضتنا الحديدية
وصوتنا الذي نضرب به اعداءنا.
خارج الصين مهما كان خطرا ولكن
اذا ما فكرت في الانقلاب على
يمتلك الجيش الصيني المنظم.
فباغنر بكين تستطيع فعل اي شيء
الوقت الذي تمتعت فيه فاجنر
موسكو بصلاحيات واسعة وتسليح
الشيوعية لشركاتها بنفس
الصلاحيات او حتى نفس درجة
مسلحة خارج بلدهما وتمتلكان نقاط
دفاع بحرية في اماكن نفوذهما
ايديها بوصلة التوجيه. ورغم
السلاح المتطور الذي سلحت به
موسكو. قبضة حديدية. التنين
الاصفر لا يدع مجالا للصدفة. ففي
امام قطار احلامنا سيدهسه القطار
دون تردد. ولكن هل من الممكن ان
تتمرد اشباح بكين وينقلب السحر
على الساحر كما فعلت فاجنر
لكم مشاهدينا هل ستنجح بكين في
انتزاع كرسي العرش من واشنطن ام
ان الضباع الامريكي سيكون لها
رأيا اخر.
سنويا وتخطط للمزيد اشباح الظل
الصينية. اسمها الرسمي ليس فاجنر
افريقيا التي تخطط استثمارات
بكين فيها مائتي مليار دولار
بجمهورية افريقيا الوسطى. كل هذا
دفع الصين لانشاء قوات امن خاصة
دعمناكم باحدث انظمة المراقبة
واقوى الاسلحة لتكونوا اعيننا
الصينية المتطورة فان كل هذا يعد
لا شيء بالنسبة للسلاح الذي
الصين ربما سيمحوها الجيش الصيني
بسلاحه من الوجود وقالتها بكين
واسيوية وكان اصحاب العيون
الضيقة يعلنونها صراحة من يقف
وكما هو حال فاجنر موسكو فعمليات
فاجنر بكين العسكرية سرية تماما.
تشترك مع قوات فاجنر الروسية في
بعض الامور. فالفرقتان تربطهما
السمراء كليبيا ونيجيريا واوغندا
والكونجو. وفي مارس الماضي تم
قتل تسعة صينيين في هجوم شنه
مسلحون على منجم ذهب اكتشف حديثا
واسيا واوروبا وامريكا الوسطى
والجنوبي. ولكن في الوقت الذي
مدربون عسكريا على اعلى مستوى.
اطلق عليها اسم فاجنر لانها
انما هي مجموعة شركات امن خاصة
تتبع الحكومة الصينية. افرادها
رعاياها لحمايتهم وحماية
استثماراتها الضخمة خصوصا في
بكين افراد شركاتها الخاصة
ودعمها لهم بكل التكنولوجيا
التسلح بل تضع بكين تلك الشركات
تحت سيطرتها المحكمة وتملك في
وقد يصل الامر لاغتيال شخصيات
رفيعة المستوى في دول افريقية
بها من اصحاب الخلفيات العسكرية
وارسالها الى الدول التي بها
في بعض الاحيان. وكان وضع العمال
الصينيين في افريقيا اسوأ حالا.
انتعش فيه اقتصاد بكين وانتشر
رعاياها في كل انحاء العالم كان
اشارتهم. نعم هم تسونامي
المستقبل وحاكم الكوكب المنتظر
باحدث الاسلحة والتقنيات
العالمية. السلاح الصيني رهن
فخلال السنوات القليلة الماضية
تعرض الكثير من العمال الصينيين
بكين تستثمر في مائة واثنتين
وخمسين دولة متفرقة بافريقيا
ففي تعرض رعايا صينيون لهجمات
مسلحة وعمليات خطف عديدة بل وقتل
علاقات مع جيوش دولتيهما
وكلتاهما تنفذان عمليات سرية
هم من العسكريين الصينيين اما
محاربون قدامى واما عساكر وضباط
لعشرات الهجمات وعمليات الخطف
وطلب فدية في دول عديدة بالقارة
الخفاء دون يسمع به احد. فتمرد
فاجنر الروسية سلط الضوء على
عملاق ظل ينمو في الخفاء. لولا
تمرد قوات فاجنر الروسي الاخير
مشروع الحزام والطريق او طريق
الحرير الجديد كما يطلق عليه
الشمالية واستراليا تحميهم
صناعية اينما ذهبوا ومسلحون
الضيقة يتحركون في صمت ومعدتهم
تتحمل ابتلاع ثلاثة ارباع
العالم. ففاجنر بكين منتشرة في
كل قارات العالم عدا امريكا
العالم. التنين الاصفر يبتلع
الكوكب. ياتي عام الفين وسبعة
ولكن كيف نشأت قوات فاجنر
الصينية وماذا تفعل في كل انحاء
منتشرة بشكل كبير في افريقيا
واسيا. يبدو ان اصحاب العيون
للانتشار الصيني الواسع مخاطره
خصوصا في قارتي افريقيا واسيا.
بكين المرعبة المنتشرة في كل
قارات العالم? وهل تستطيع التمرد
عشر ليسيطر التنين الصيني على
معظم اقتصاد العالم من خلال
سيتركه الضبع الامريكي يفعل ما
يحلو له ويسلمه مقاليد حكم
شركات الامن الصينية المسلحة
والتي اكتشف العالم مؤخرا انها
يخطط له التنين الصيني الذي
لابتلاع الكوكب في معدته؟ وهل
تصنع بكين عملاقا مرعبا ظل ينمو
في الظلام. وهى تعلن عن نسخة
महा
بمنتجاتهم واحكموا قبضتهم عليها
ولم يكتفوا بذلك. بل غزوا
العالم بهدوء لتعرف اجابة كل تلك
الاسئلة تابع الفيديو للنهاية.
على الصين كما فعلت فاجنر موسكو
مع بوتين? وما هو المشروع الذي
ضد بوتين لظلت قوات فاغنر
الصينية عملاقا ينمو ويعمل في
اخرى من قوات فاغنر الروسية ولكن
على طريقتها. ما هي قوات فاجنر
اصحاب العيون الضيقة صنعوا نسخة
من كل شيء. غزوا اسواق العالم
كان كيقتلني.
है في تخبط. الصين تريد ان تضع
الكوكب كله في جوال وتمشي به.
بسلاحهم ملوك السلاح في العالم
امريكا والقارة العجوز. واليوم